all right cracking open the pft pm
mailbag to wrap up this friday edition
of pftp and we still have another
segment after that though but this is
the last significant segment with time
and heft and substance at least as it
relates to the things shireen says not
to anything that i may have to say at
playoff cap here's the first question
how likely is it that jim harbaugh comes
back to the nfl and if so how likely
will it be the bears how about the
buccaneers if the season ends badly
first of all sharing what's your thought
on the possibility of harbaugh coming
back i had heard a couple of weeks ago
teams are evaluating him that he's
interested in coming back this was all
happening at the time we were hearing
reports that he had an extension in line
with michigan and it was a done deal
until it wasn't
i think everything is very tenuous and i
think a lot of it depends upon nfl
interest do you think he'll be back and
if so where
well he has 6.4 million left on his
contract that runs through 2021 so it'll
be interesting to see what he and
michigan decide to do
i to me the luster's off jim harbaugh i
mean he went to michigan his alma mater
and he was supposed to be all that and
groom all these quarterbacks and they've
been terrible and two and four this year
and just really struggled and it's kind
of been that way since he got there i
but i do think having said all that that
he's more likely to return to the nfl
than he is to go somewhere else in in
the college ranks and i don't know where
that would be but i if it was me i don't
want jim harbaugh i know he's been to a
super bowl but i would go with with some
other one of these assistants the eric b
enemies or whoever it might be and give
one of them a chance to to become a head
coach rather than
recirculate jim harbaugh again
the difference is you know that harbaugh
can do it you don't know that an
offensive or defensive coordinator can
do it and we see that from time to time
where a coach and to me the best example
or the worst example is brad childress
never should have been a head coach got
more time than he should have in
minnesota great as an offensive
coordinator not great as a head coach
fundamentally different job we know jim
harbaugh can do it and he did it at a
very high level for his four years with
the 49ers the issue with harbaugh is
that he wears out his welcome quickly
that was a point that was made vividly
in a real sports with brian gumbel
profile of harbaugh several years ago
and one of my favorite jim harbaugh
stories it comes from gary meyer's book
that looks at the relationship between
nfl figures and their fathers and when
jim harbaugh was a kid and his dad
jack was
a college football coach and had to move
every so often one of the times when it
was time to move jim said that's okay i
ran out of friends
so
you know jim's only been four years four
years four years everywhere in his
career as a coach before this michigan
stop i don't know six years
is
maybe he's ready to move on and maybe
they're ready to get in the hell out of
there shireen
yeah i think that's probably the case
mike it might be time for him to go
somewhere else and a good break for
michigan and a good break from
for him
let me ask you this
would he bring back colin kaepernick
would he give would he be the guy to
give colin kaepernick a second chance
the nfl you keep saying that
but if he gets back in does it happen
i interviewed jim harbaugh in 2017
when colin kaepernick was in the early
stages of being shunned by the nfl and i
asked him point blank about kaepernick
and he said kaepernick is a guy with
whom you can win championships with an s
so
if jim harbaugh comes back and if he has
any power over personnel
this is your opportunity this is your
chance we'll see if he puts his money
where his mouth is and brings kaepernick
back and will that be part of the
negotiation on the way in hey if i take
this job i just want you to know i'm
bringing in colin kaepernick are you
okay with it that could be a compelling
wrinkle to all of this and frankly all
the more reason to root for jim harbaugh
to come back to the nfl i
i think he will be at some point and
maybe it will be this year but i feel
like he he has unfinished business at
the nfl level and he's a better coach at
the nfl level than he was at the college
level
spa demand which potential job opening
atlanta chargers possibly jets likely
lions texans has the most allure shireen
which one do you like the best
i would take the chargers job and a
heartbeat mike there's only four teams
in the nfl right now that are ranked in
the top ten in offense and defense
chargers are one of those teams and and
i know bill parcells always said your
record is what it says it is that that's
what you are but i would say in the
chargers case i think they're better
than what their record is i think
coaching has cost them i think special
teams has cost them they have the
offense and the defense and the
franchise quarterback to win now their
records should be better and i think
cost coaching has cost them i think you
can go in there and you have a playoff
team right away in the chargers right
the day you step in that job you have a
playoff contender
yeah chronic underachievers great talent
better talent than the raiders frankly
and
uh i i think that the fact that they
haven't fulfilled their potential the
past couple of years makes it harder to
bring back anthony that would be the job
i want not a fan of the 13 california
income tax but you can handle that in
the job negotiations the texans are the
other one that intrigues me but again
the jack easter bee angle i want to know
exactly where i stand and where he
stands and how much power he has over me
how much power i have over him and uh uh
frankly i i wouldn't want my
relationship with the owner to be
complicated by someone who isn't held to
the same standard of winning and losing
that i am so i'll agree with you
chargers would be the most attractive if
it comes open i don't know 40. do you
think there's a real chance wade
phillips could go back to the cowboys
shireen
i know wade phillips wants back in the
game but i don't think it's going to be
in dallas and i don't frankly think he
ever gets a chance to coach again i
think that ship has sailed for wade
phillips maybe somebody brings him in as
a senior assistant type thing on defense
something like that i don't know but i
don't think he'll come back here i do
think the cowboys make a change a
defensive coordinator position after
this year they get move on from mike
nolan maybe it's tomasula who gets that
chance maybe they bring in somebody else
but i don't think it will be wade
phillips
i just wonder if coaches head coaches
are threatened by the presence of a wade
phillips because he's got the gravitas
he's got the name recognition players
love him does he in any way he's got
that very dry sense of humor you have to
be pretty damn secure in yourself as the
coach of the team to have wade there
he's very very dry and sometimes you
can't tell if he's messing with you or
not and uh there aren't a whole lot of
coaches that would be perfectly
comfortable handing their defense over
or having wade phillips in a position of
significant influence last one at sims
homies would an aaron rodgers super bowl
win over patrick mahomes change the tom
brady aaron rodgers goat conversation i
know chris sims would hope so
sharing let me let me take first crack
at this one yeah
aaron rodgers get the two super bowl
wins i don't care if he if he beats
johnny unitas by traveling through time
i don't care who he wins it's only two
tom brady's got six that's what matters
aaron rodgers needs to at least at least
get to three or four before we even
begin to consider him as the greatest of
all time because brady has six
uh no question about it i mean he's got
the six super bowl rings he's a
four-time super bowl mvp he's a
three-time nfl mvp and i know rogers may
get his third this year but he only has
one super bowl mvp and only one super
bowl ring and it is amazing to me mike
that he only has one ring and the same
with favre like you would think that
these are guys that were going to get
multiple rings and probably talked about
that after that first super bowl you
know you go get the second it hasn't
happened which i i think you start to
think about the chiefs in this in this
case too and i know they look like the
best team and all that we talk about a
dynasty but we've seen so many times
these great quarterbacks can't get that
second ring that we think they should
have had and if they get two like peyton
it took him forever to get his second he
never got the third
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports